THAT TO HAPPEN.
CAROLIA
WHISTLE, SO THAT'S A GOOD
THING. NO. HE BLEW UPT ACROSS W
AND HE HAD TO
DEAL WITH, AS WELL, FROM
WENNBERG.
THAT HOCKEY,
BEAR STOP, RIGHT ON GRUBAUER
WITH THE SAVE.
HE G NATURE OF
RAANTA . OPPOSITEER
SAY.
DAY YESTERDAY, AND LET THE
TRAFFIC DISSIPATE.
>> Mike: EXACTLY.
SHOT, BUT IT
OFF THE MARK.
RAANTA MAKES THE FIRST DATE,
AND WENNBERG POPS THIS ONE ONE
BIRD THAT DISRUPTS RAANTA'S
VISION JUST ENOUGH. NIEDERREITE
THE POWER-PLKEEPS ALIVE, AND AN
QUICK ANSWER FROM THE KRAKEN
SHE COULDN'T LOCATE IT IN TIME.
HECK OF A PASS IN TRANSITION,
AND JUST AN ALL WORLD SHOT FROM
PICKED UP BY SKJEI, SKJEI IS
DRY.
16th OF THE SEASON, ANOTHER
POWER-UNCANNY CHEMISTRY
PASS FROM SEBASTIAN
ALONG THE BOARDS.
WAS THIS A STICK, WENNBERG, AND
RON TO
VETERAN PLAYER.NET AND
CONVERGING. NO BETTER EXAMPLE
THAN THAT GOAL THAT TIME
NATIONS GETS ON THE AFTER HE
SUPPORTED ANDREI IN THE
TRENCHES.
HE SPENDS OFOFTHEN ONCE A
PENDING AND AND RAANTA GOT
CAUGHT  IN THE CENTER ZONE,
CENTER ZONE FOR BOSTON, BARRY I
NEED TO REACH,  AND STAAL , IT
OUT OF HIS OWN.
>> Tripp: THE SHORT
SIDE. ,